families deflected by Davis Davis comes
away with it and throws it down a little
bit of a footrace he was able to get
past Morris the percentage goes up a
little bit he was on fire when he was
with the Knicks earlier this season
James took a hard hit
Thanks at home and a chance for a
three-point play so they can attack
early in the clock
James just wipes you have to have a guy
who's willing to be a glue connector
type of guy and still be great pass
inside James to Davis that's some sweet
team basketball there what a play by
LeBron I mean he knew Leonard was
rotating before the ball hit his hand
and that ability to touch it to Davis is
special Wow there's a sprained knee oh
you got a really wait him next week but
does home court if you're playing on the
same court it really matters as Davis
it's a tough shot Dwight Howard the
rebound slapped out of his hands Reggie
Jackson comes up with the loose ball
goes inside reversed blocked by James
but right to Jamaica green who misses
and Kuzma another rebound trying to use
the rim as protection but James was
gonna get it on eat this is the largest
lead he were the first half James draws
the foul the strength again
count it and one Wow against the
strength and length of Leonard just up
and threw him for a three-point play I
mean point-blank at the basket there on
the takes of Jebel fires and can't hit
rebound deflected still loose picked up
by James throws it inside and the finish
for Markieff Morris not a lot of assists
here in the first half
as James easily gets to the rim James
the offensive board cross-court to
Bradley Avery Bradley in and out and in
again by the no-look pass you think he's
going to Anthony Davis he waits until
Avery Bradley gets to his spot on point
pass step and rhythm tell you what the
Lakers it fighting Jeff you have driving
me a little crazy right now today he
throws the ball at his feet he's got to
be penalized and I don't care how nice
the guy is this is a technical foul how
about the other two Davis calling Ford
five on the 24 goes across the lane
little old-fashioned hook beautiful move
there from Anthony Davis Davis runs down
and lays it up with the foul
hurt his dribble dead cut to the hoop
takes the contact and delay and that's
quality offense for the Lakers
Errol picks up his third all right Lisa
backer is giving that their playoff lost
voice sound as LeBron James gets the
free metal Lakers go up by seven the
wine Leonard guarding LeBron James
drives past him layup is good
and the foul Leonard just turned his
head and James with a burst of speed to
the rim like Leonard did there's no help
that can help you to wreck line drive
[Applause]
easy finish and one drives hop step in
the paint to Davis for the slam a
terrific pass from LeBron James for his
ninth assist this building is filled
with Laker jerseys James drives lab
County and the
lebron james putting on the finishing
touches
[Applause]
get head of steam against Morris
Leonard chooses not to help
now tell you what after the game Lisa is
going to talk to LeBron hopefully and
he's going to say it's just enough
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content